denise ccsd returning to class after
spring break but some staff used the
first day back to send a message to the
district a rally was held outside of el
dorado high school calling for an end to
violence on campuses you will remember a
teacher was attacked by a student at the
campus earlier on this month that
student is now charged with attempted
murder and tonight we hear from a
student of that teacher who says it's
not the same in class without her this
is more and more people say safety
should be a top priority for the
district madison kimbrough was at
today's rally joins us live in the
northeast valley with the story madison
today's rally really unified a bunch of
student staff and teachers and they say
after that attack having more campus
monitoring and security are not
negotiable
even if it's support staff more
administration
more teachers we just need more bodies
than people that want to be here that
was veron tucker one of five campus
monitors at el dorado high school he
along with others heading the rally
tuesday say staying fully staffed is a
struggle we have hundreds of
campus security monitor positions that
are open and the district can't get
anybody to come and work at these
positions because they don't pay enough
tuesday's rally hosted by the education
support employees association had about
50 participants with the goal of
bringing awareness to the issue of
violence in our schools josie ramirez a
student of the eldorado high school
teacher who was attacked says she didn't
even know that her teacher had been hurt
until the day after going back to school
the next day with just information of a
teacher being assaulted and then figure
out on your own it was your teacher was
it was i was left
with no words and tuesday an
announcement about that teacher was made
leaving ramirez to wonder if she'll ever
see her again i had her class today
actually she wasn't there you know and
the substitute did tell us that she
wasn't going to be there for the rest of
the year i heard that she's recovering
at home and you know she's taking her
time to herself
here at el dorado high school today
students and teachers tell me there was
more of a police presence on campus but
as far as monitoring in the hallways
that's still an issue reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now